so I had an idea well two actually but
I'm gonna I'm gonna start off with the
first one which is you might know that I
play a lot of roller coaster can three
well obviously my youtube channel and
all that but I just my last play is
barely any of the actual time that I
spent in game and it's definitely not
the real thing that I learned from or
experiment in or do anything in that you
know I really feel like doing sometimes
and this is why really a lot of the
things that I do in roller coaster can
three that I sometimes feel like our
record worthy is just things that never
go into my channel and many of these
things actually do end up as roller
coasters basically follow for roller
coasters and just the random buildings
that I add around it or environments and
so eventually do get a video but never
really a time much video or any
explanation or any real love other than
that so today is going to be a bit of an
experiment I work I woke up this morning
and that was my second idea I just felt
like building a cathedral and to be very
honest I've never actually tried
building one of these and I'm not too
experienced in the sets that you need
for this kind of thing but I didn't go
into this video entirely unexperienced
because i started this this morning
started building some towers didn't
really work out all that well so i
decided to just start again and start
working in a Cathedral and then I was
halfway through done and then no SI d 4
SPD or no SPD for SI I can't remember
that but regardless it crushed and while
quite quite frankly I was pretty pissed
off at that point and then that one
pissed-off silver at decided that he
would just not be let down by that and
rebuilt the building while in a stream
and then actually turned out to be a
pretty pretty nice stream and which I
actually got a lot of work done this
building was built in two and a half
hours which is actually pretty much a
record time for me and I'm pretty sure
for many people as well because it does
take a lot of time to build buildings
and all across the country especially
buildings that are this big and this
detailed and certainly because this is a
theme that I've really tried before and
as you might also see there are quite
some obscure sets in this because the
Gothic theme as a whole is so
early done that there aren't many sets
out there which you can actually use to
make the buildings with so i got like i
got some very obscure assets that i
don't even know the name of and i wasn't
too big of a fan of most of the sets
they're not very versatile and don't
really have too many details in them but
the textures are just downright amazing
and if you do place if you do pay close
attention you'll see that a lot of ways
used in this is actually from Ralphie's
medieval and station ships castle said
things like that so you can actually use
many things oh and the Arabian sets
because the Arabian sets are good for
anything you can really build anything
with the Arabian sets they're very
versatile and especially in this case
because they kind of look like Gothic
arches is also pretty nice but it really
turned out that the shape is very
important when you're building a gothic
and while Cathedral in general and the
textures are also quite important so
that is man is really just a choice of
custom scenery because I write some
other walls but rarely any of them
really worked out as a church kind of
texture and these ones I'm not to
incredibly happy about but they work
pretty well the only thing that I'm not
sure about is under windows down there
on the bottom but there weren't any real
good brick patterns that I could use
that and can we fit the rest of the
textures so I decided to go for these
windows anyway and what is fun about
this theme is that it's but that it's
pretty much a spam festive details and
although that there are some downsides
to that there is the fact that it does
take a little bit of time to just get
those extra details in I do have to find
some sets which you can use the details
from it does help that when you feel
like something doesn't look that good
yet you can just keep it and spam
details on it and eventually it might
just look good which is definitely what
happens with some things like this and
it's definitely what happened with the
walls on the sides here and yeah what I
had on the walls here it was I wasn't
sure if I really wanted to keep the
building in this kind of shape because
as you can see it's a pretty standard
and straight to the point shape
and you've just got the one straight
kind of main body of the church and the
two little wings on the sides and of
course the dome in the middle but the
issue that I had initially was the fact
that you only have a couple of walls and
not much interesting going interesting
stuff going on in terms of in terms of
perspective because usually what you
want to have in a building if you really
want to get the building to look cool
from perspectives is you wanna have some
layering going on you and have some
places within the building that have
different shapes and different heights
than others that makes it a lot more
interesting to look at but many
cathedrals are just one big wall of
things and the only thing that has that
have conceded that okay the only thing
that cathedrals have going for them is
that amazing amount of detail and how
the sculptures and things on the sides
but you can't really do that in rolla Co
second three but I guess in the end it
came it did come up pretty well mainly
due to the fact that there's so many
custom scenery sets that actually turn
out to work a lot better than I expected
I never really expected to be using
that's after links at this much for this
building and even the Walt Disney World
Council is in here quite a lot it is
actually the little towers on the site
you can see they're usually you have
like gothic pillars but I guess these
medieval towers actually do the same
kind of job and we're halfway through
the time lapse here but not it not even
halfway through the building of this
building and yeah that's all so i guess
i was actually handy the second half of
building this building went a lot slow
because it did involve experimenting
with things as you can see trying to get
there the right dormers and trying to
get the right term everything basically
because the first half was built just
after a copy that I still kind of had in
my head after I hopefully finished that
first Cathedral hand and got the error
which was pretty handy it was almost
like a speed build especially in
beginning so that's pretty efficient for
the time lapse but in the end it was
pretty hard to get some pieces right
just because there was such a lack of
good gothic scenery well I guess I did
work out in the end especially with
foliage around it but you'll see that
soon
and one other problem that I did have
was dormers one of the main sets that I
used for this yeah surprisingly was
stationed ships ghost Kevin because
there isn't really too much because some
scenery out there with textures like
this like the real dark textures but
also enough details that you can add to
kind of make it look like a cathedral
and that is really what i needed in this
case so there was actually a lot more of
Satan Jim's ghost Kevin going on that I
initially wanted but that also caused
things like I was looking for dormers
and I could hardly find any damas that I
really liked in the end I just had to
settle for a couple of ones that I was
just okay with and there was also the
fact that I had a couple of Gothic sets
from like the deepest points of the
internet there were like some gothic
sets from 2008 and earlier on and you
know that they're pretty okay especially
considering that they're pretty old set
but they all have a full tile placement
and I was ready to kick some custom
scenery creators in the face right there
but that wouldn't be really nice but
thing is there are just some areas where
you want to have those hostile
placements like in the entrance over
here and I just couldn't get that
because of the custom scenery
limitations so that was a bit of a
problem as well so after all it was
almost more working around limitations
because with a cathedral you or you
already have a kind of set way to build
the building in terms of shape and
details and certain rules that you have
to follow but it was more like I had to
find the right custom January to
actually built those things which I knew
I would have to add to a cathedral so
that was it probably the biggest issue
at this point but you know I didn't see
too many built too many people building
cathedrals and especially not using the
old actual gothic sets and I of course I
do see it sometimes but I feel like it's
something that you know could be done
more often because at first when I
figured I would do this I really only
did this because I was I just felt like
doing it and then opened my pc and just
rolled with it but in hindsight these
things can actually more useful than I
initially expected because you could use
this in a medieval park because churches
do
they have somewhat of a big importance
in medieval worlds and you know it could
even work in fantasy worlds and just
anything where churches are you know
come into play it could be very useful
and what I see most people using is just
the old station Jim's castle sets with
the battlements and things like that but
really there's a lot of options that you
can use for a cathedral there's so many
pieces that are not meant for this thing
because rarely anyone built cathedrals
but are actually useful like the
medieval sets and the Arabian sets and
this is this is actually one of the most
fun builds that up happening quite a
while Bronson I haven't played Monaco
second three as much lately because of
exams and no having to study and general
nuisances like that but no this is this
is still been really awesome but I want
to go on to serious business because
like I just said in the intro of this
video which I I guess I didn't really
talk too much about is that I kind of
want to make this in a series and it's
not necessarily going to be a series
like episode 1 2 3 and we're gonna do
this and there's an earnest it's the
fact that you know there are so many
moments when I open roller coaster can
three and I just feel like building
something something completely random
that has nothing to do with any of the
projects that i currently have just an
idea that pops up in my mind and I went
to try and roller coaster 3 which which
was what happened with this Cathedral
but it honestly happens quite often and
with many things and I feel like this
could potentially be content for the
channel now I don't know if people are
really interested in this but i'm
probably going to do it regardless
really because for one I feel like I am
I could be releasing more because I play
this game quite often and I don't record
a lot of what I actually play with it
and people could possibly learn from it
and I could learn from it as well and
you know it's just fun in general i
guess and it's definitely just something
that I went to get up on the channel
because right now I'm focusing so much
on the let's play but that is only one
Pike there's only one theme and you know
for myself I I also feel like if I was
too long for one park or one certain
theme and don't do too much else it just
starts getting boring
and I start losing interest sometimes
you just have to do whatever it comes up
in your mind and just try doing that and
you know it's also the times when I feel
like you are the most creative
creativity is something that you can't
force upon yourself I guess and this is
not these are not words that I live by I
just came up with that at random in
class sometime and that I suddenly just
remembered that I have no idea why but
it is pretty relevant at this point yeah
because I do actually find myself being
best at building things when I just
completely don't care about any
obligations i have and just think of
something and feel like yes i want to
build this and then just go for it that
is the best moment you can possibly want
to do anything and if you if you're
inspired to do something just finish it
right away because if you just stop
somewhere like halfway through a build
or something that you might just lose
interest over time and just opening your
up your game to make something small and
something that you really feel like
doing is I think the best way to build
something awesome in Monaco circuit 3
now here are some pictures of this
building we actually had a bit of a
photo ish kind of like a photo shoot in
the stream where I was just trying to
test different times a day and different
perspectives on the building and I'm
pretty happy about it don't know if I'm
really going to use this for anything
but you know at some point in time when
I feel like it i might just place this
thing somewhere in the mountains and add
some cool landscapes around it instead
of just a simple path and some random
trees and see how it looks in that case
and maybe even edited know it could look
pretty awesome so we'll see in the
future anyway thanks for watching and
I'll see you all next time